well this is Gavin I Gavin my name is
Colin Valenti I'm calling from master
travel incorporated tell you about an
exciting living time off an exclusive
Las Vegas getaway time to tell you about
this new package you know what I would
love to but I just don't have the time
hello hello she's gone Valenti master
travel incorporated I'm every service hi
Karan Valenti my name is Gavin I think
we just talked did we get disconnected
yeah no I mean yeah I hung up on you
well uh why would you do that
I mean are you even are you even allowed
to do that
what are you going to buy the Las Vegas
package well I mean probably not but
that's not the point to point it this is
Colin yeah Valenti listen I don't crawl
up your ass instead of shop there
what the [ __ ] do you are what is your
deal huh you don't want the biggest
package so I don't want to talk this is
a favorite wasting our time don't you
dare hang up that phone okay
why I said and I why should what if I
wanted the Vegas package will you you
know what I want the Vegas package sure
you do
[Music]
okay thank you for your business
well I hope you learned his new call
scripts are really great yeah I know
right
do you want Kathy
you